on this episode we talk about Germany my
impending tragic death and being
addicted to the Internet second
internship you ask questions and I
answer them this is the askgaryvee
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk in
assembly some 84 of the ask gary vee
show like that meerkat that was just for
the meerkat audience who said my energy
was wack for 83 which it was because i
was pissed because I lost a basketball
game deal with it
one thing I'm dealing with is we just
opened a 12th floor a third floor here
at vaynermedia and I don't know if it's
because it's a good Friday but like we
are not as packed in on this floor and
the energy level is concerning so we'll
be taping an episode taping it like that
we'll be recording we'll be producing an
episode from floor 12 very shortly so
looking forward to that big shout out to
Copenhagen I'm going there next week
that excites me for a conference and
let's get into the show India ready all
right Jill asks one are you gonna pursue
my idea to do you get a lot of quality
ideas when you crowdsource a question
and three do you crowdsource ideas more
to engage with your audience but I
actually get serious ideas like mine
Jill this is a great question first and
foremost it is not you only your idea
that idea of a subscription wine thing
has been going on oh I don't know for
about five and a half six seven years
now I've been pounded with that idea but
to answer if we're gonna do it the
answer is I'm not sure why I've been
getting more involved with Wine Library
lately there's a lot of different
objectives that I want to accomplish
that are more top of list but the the
kind of garyvee subscription or wine
library subscription thing is definitely
interesting and it's something we're
pondering I mean one month clubs have
been around forever and of course
personalization or all the other
variables you can add to it get it got
it solid idea love your picture by the
way on Instagram
yeah I think we get quality ideas and
and more importantly quality subjective
right to me it's my form of listening
and so yeah I think I get some quality
ideas at times I mean the truth is I to
answer the third part of your question
do I do it
to engage or or am I really looking for
the ideas you know I'm very in Soleri
with my ideas I don't like getting ideas
from other places and so I do it more to
engage and to listen and to get a pulse
and to collect and their inputs they're
lightweight like it would be rare for me
to just take Stefan's idea but hearing
Stefan's idea and India's ideas and D
Rock's ideas and stun one's ideas and
just they're all little inputs and then
it forms some version I always feel like
I've got to put my sprinkles on it
that's been successful for me and so I
think that I'm taking the inputs of the
world so I do so much listening so much
engaging to get to like an 85 90 percent
place and then I do my thing on top of
that and that's one of the good stuff
comes from Megan this is a great
question I often say that money and fame
don't change anybody they just expose
who someone actually is at a bigger
scale and there's an enormous part of me
that believes there's a lot of truth in
that in technology as well right we're
not making you know people like I had
this funny argument with this guy at
Wine Library the other day where he was
like you know all these phones no but
the art of like talking to each other I
was in speakers I was in Starbucks this
was great I was in Starbucks and
everybody was head down nobody was
talking to each other I was like where
were you he's like New York I'm like all
right let's talk about this for a second
I'm like do you think 13 years ago at
Starbucks that people were just yapping
with each other like hey brother great
shirt that's not how New York rolls my
man and so I I think that all that
technology is doing is is making more
visible what we actually were going to
do I mean I do believe the far majority
of people are introverted at first at
scale by math if you if you ask me or
any I think common sense person in
society I think we'd all agree I'm
looking for some Reformation here like
there's
more people they're gonna sit either
timid or middle timid or somewhat timid
then somebody was just gonna roll up I
mean the reason we love and hate the
like the people that just roll up and
are loud he got him
really on that angle you get him you got
Gabe right there like the reason Gabe
who works at vaynermedia is someone that
so many people know is because he's loud
as [ __ ] right and some people love it
and some people hate it right but that's
why he's an extrovert extreme he's
probably like singing his song right now
looks like he's in a meeting he's
probably just doing some drake lyrics
while he works i mean and so I think
that it's important for us to understand
that yeah first of all could you be
having an addiction sure I mean look I
mean I think everybody's addicted to
their cellular device I fully believe
that every single person's addicted to
their cell phone like straight up and so
it may be but I would say this I think
that it's great for all the introverts
or the people that don't like the party
and don't like to go out what they were
doing before where they were interacting
with the television I mean let's call it
what it is or with like a very small
group of one or two friends who equally
were close and location to them and were
like that now people can really
communicate at scale with the people
have similar interests find new people
and all that kind of stuff and so I
think that you are fine I think your
picture is rad I think you and I are
friends
max asks I'm from Germany where your cat
is nothing more than a cute animal and
Twitter isn't even as dominant as it is
in the US would you recommend that I
still go there and wait
max I think that the question is very
solid but actually you should have been
able to level up and figure it out for
yourself here's what I mean by that it's
the same thesis that I talk about in the
US a meerkat is just an animal in the
u.s. to like and so is periscope and so
a snapchat 38 months ago like like yes
every cut like here's an answer will
every country like the same social
networking apps and they will hit scale
absolutely not it's funny unfortunately
as India was reading the question I know
that Twitter never popped to real scale
at Germany I was gonna say that you said
in the question so look I think that
it's super important for you to
understand what I mean by sit there and
hope the upside of being an early mover
in a new platform that has the potential
to pop is so much greater than the
downside of going to a new platform and
wasting your four or five or ten weeks
or ten months and it didn't pop and
that's why I will always do it that's
about as basic as it gets that was
probably the best way that I've ever
articulated it so thank you max Lou
termini for putting me in a position to
succeed right now because that's it
that's just it it's just that simple
especially when you're an entrepreneur
and time is what you have not money you
entrepreneurs in the vaynernation are
pissing me off to such an extreme
because you're debating these things and
you cry that you don't have enough money
to compete with the big guys but then
you cry about wasting your time oh you
mean the only goddamn asset you have
besides your raw talent to have any
potential to win yeah I think it's a
good use your time hey Gary its Brandon
from human crime Washington DC we do a
great job of customers in the store how
do we take that same level of experience
so you know I think you guys a team at
hue and cry need to really think about
what people want in a retail store so
you figured that out and I think the way
you do it is through a survey monkey or
a survey or some data of what do people
want in
in an online experience I mean it's
about delivering people what they want
where they want it so a lot of times
people trying to impose the old world to
the new world meaning okay
so on our website we're gonna make a
video for everything or we're gonna
we're gonna put a live person like app
or we're gonna put our toll-free number
calling it like you know I and everybody
in this room wants good ui/ux
I want to be fast I want to get in and
out and speed matters to me when I
online shop more than like it's funny I
actually n listen everybody has
different behaviors but I should just be
fun Steve I'm gonna make a statement and
I want to hear your version of it well
actually you know I hate shopping but it
for God I guess jet sure like I'm trying
to think I just don't like shopping but
I was about to say in online shopping
but I can't even order unlike seamless
well actually I do order and save us do
you know that I'm not capable of calling
a restaurant and ordering food for
myself that it is literally one of the
three or four things that cripples me
the most like that if Lizzie just said
hey can you call an order dinner so what
did you do before seamless yeah I had
somebody else do it
my wife prior to that age a prior to
that my parents prior to that
girlfriends like I would just never I
never did it was a joke it just
suffocates me the notion of like being
on the phone to order something
suffocates me yeah anyway seamless
worked for me the app and that's why it
works but where I was about to go was in
online stuff I need fast in offline site
I can like schmooze a little bit but
then I realized no I don't and so I only
value speed because time is the thing I
like the most
India do you like shopping yeah okay
okay are your habits different online
than they are in real life like will you
spend 40 minutes in a store looking at
stuff and will you spend 40 minutes
looking at stuff on a website
you're more surgical do you use
Pinterest or other things in theory that
are getting you there online that's
where it gets interesting right I think
there's something in there and that's
where my intuition is right even though
I'm not a shopper I understand shoppers
which is why I led the questions if you
pay attention very carefully I think it
comes down to realizing that people want
to be surgical an execution oriented on
your site and you as a marketing engine
need to be great at creating discovery
across the whole web and then funneling
it to surgical execution on your site
that was a tremendous advice Andrew
asked if you were to tragically die
today how well would they know what do
you do in the long term without its CEO
have you been satisfied with wine
library's performance since leaving to
focus on vaynermedia and this is a great
question I mean I always say everything
stems from the top and and so I mean I'm
trying to think about how I want to
answer this question meaning AJ's
ridiculously capable I don't think the
company would do as well mainly because
he just had his big brother and mentor
died and so even though he's capable I
would assume that he'd be pretty torn up
he better be and so you know I think
that he would struggle with that and I
don't think he loves client services
enough to like persevere and you'd be
like what is it all worth anyway who
cares you know like so I think I think
vein you know on the flip side there's
an interesting thing believe it or not
this is a weird thing though AJ is
hands-down the most capable person to be
the CEO of vaynermedia I could almost
see him not wanting to do it and I could
almost see so many people here
internally saying no we have to continue
the hustle and so it'd be interesting I
think we built a very interesting
culture here
similarly Brandon runs wine library with
my dad and Bobby and Justins all family
my best friend my brother-in-law my
cousin my dad you know my ego made me
think that while I we would hurt more
than it did without me there so to
answer your question I am happy with how
Wine Library is performed with me not
there that being
do I think it could be way way way way
better of course I mean I think I'm
great and so do I think the businesses
are better off without me than with me
absolutely not are they are they in
places where they won't go out of
business
absolutely are they in places where they
have no prayer of the hyper-growth that
I create when I'm the operator that's
for damn sure
the biggest thing that I create is the
ability to grow big businesses fastest
[ __ ] like like that's gonna end up being
my legacy if I do it one more time I'm
now on business number two that I've
taken in a 36 month period with no cash
infusion two very big Heights that is a
very difficult task in a cash flow basis
not fun you know the companies that grow
big on funding that makes sense like you
know the ubers and companies way better
than what I've executed but still when
you have hundreds of millions of dollars
in funding the speed is what I'm talking
about the business well in a non funded
business to be able to build that speed
that takes an incredible game of chicken
because you're playing cash flow versus
growth being able to for you know you
know I'm proud I am that we've never had
layoffs because we've lost a client that
is unheard of in agency world and it's
rental unheard up for the fastest
growing agency of all time in people
like we're I'm proud that is what I'm
uniquely great at so they won't grow as
fast but there's enormous talent around
me that is able to do with their thing
now that being said I'm so much not only
the executional leader of my friends and
families and business I think I'm the
emotional leader with a lot of them too
and so I I would think that they would
really struggle with my absence and
would would would crumble into little
holes I'm just kidding
I think I think they would struggle with
that cool what do we ask here yeah oh
gosh a day yeah oh [ __ ] I forgot about
the question of the day what are you
doing this weekend you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
you